Hi class, Dr. Jim here.
We're now starting to look at the individual systems and so today is a really important
lecture looking at how animals, animals themselves and so really the vertebrates, but we're going
to talk about other animals as well, how we are able to conserve water and so one of the
biggest problems we have being on land is not having water surround us and so how do
we manage making sure that we don't dry up, that we don't become dehydrated because water
is always being evaporated from our bodies and really we're trying to minimize as much
water loss as possible and so that's the biggest thing and so today we're going to look at
the excretion system of animals and again we're going to look at why these things are so important
because again if we lose all our water we're in really big trouble and so this kind of
goes along with what we talked about earlier in chapter 32 looking at thermal regulation
and regulation of the endocrine system and some of these other things and so what this
is looking at specifically is how do animals regulate the water loss or water intake and
water loss and again it all evolves around the excretion system.
Now in humans again we have our kidneys, the kidneys play a big role in filtering our blood
and again production of urine which then travels down the ureter to the bladder and then finally
out the urethra.
In other animals like insects and that they really don't have a set of kidneys but what
they have are these things called milk piggy and tubules which help pull out different
nutrients out of the hemocil which is kind of the fluid that surrounds their body.
They pull out these nutrients and that stuff that they don't need are waste and toxins
and that stuff especially ammonia and that and it really comes out really dry and what
they secrete out is dry waste including muric acid and so again ammonia is always the biggest
issue in any of these things.
Again looking at other animals very similar when we look at other animals like vertebrates
again kidneys, ureters, the bladder and urethra and again the kidneys work the same way and
we're going to talk about why vertebrates or mammals in general have become so successful
in land because of the development of these kidneys.
In order to thrive in land you need to minimize your water loss and so either you're going
to be attached to the water and stuck with the water like amphibians where again they
have rudimentary kidneys and that stuff and they work pretty well but again they have
to be in very moist environments where mammals have evolved enough so that we really don't
need source of water close by obviously we need to drink water and do those different
things but we're not dependent on water as much as say a fish or amphibian is since we're
now on land and so we'll look at some of the reasons why that is today.
So again we're going to talk about what type of osmo regulation systems do animals have
and again osmo regulation is controlling the amount of water and water loss and we'll look
at that so we're going to go back to osmosis again and look at all that good stuff and
then we're going to look at is there a difference between marine, freshwater, terrestrial animals
and how they deal with water loss and you're going to see there is a big difference in
what type of minerals you have and all those different things and then finally like I said
before how have mammals adapted their kidneys to be in land and so we're going to really
take a close look at not only the humans but again really at all mammals and even focusing
on a little of those that grow in or that grow that live in very warm dry environments
like the desert and see what they do differently to conserve water because that is always the
issue when we're talking about living on land and especially dry environments.
So today we're going to look at again looking at osmo regulation and again this is the ability
to manage your water loss and so osmo regulation is the general term in which animals control
their solute concentrations and again it's a balance of water gain and loss and again
there are several mechanisms involved in excretion that look at this to get rid of nitrogen as
metabolites and so like I said in insects they pretty much produce a dry waste looking
and making uric acid whereas in humans we produce urine and again it has urea and some
other things and so we'll take a look at some of these different structures as we go along.
Now osmolarity is the concentration of solute in a solution and again it is looking at how
water moves across the membrane and so this is getting back to the early original osmosis
moving to water and so the one golden rule that you have to remember is water is always
going to move towards the solute and the solute could be anything typically we always think
of salt but it could be really anything you can talk about sugar molasses you know proteins
nucleic acids anything that's a solute is dissolved in water.
Now water is always going to try and equal everything out in biology we always want to
make everything equal and so whenever you think about these situations we want to make
sure that we try to get to an iso osmotic solution and so again what happens here in
this example here is that water is always going to move from a place where you have lower
solute or concentration to higher solute concentration and so because water wants to dissolve the
solute to get these two sides equal and so that's the idea in this situation.
Now we have again some organisms that are called osmoconformers meaning that they basically
adjust to their environment so if they're a really fresh water place or non-sulted place
they adjust their bodies to that where as if they're in a very salty place they can
adjust their systems an example of an osmoconformer would be a jellyfish and again they're very
simple animals and they can adjust their salt concentrations based on the environment
they're in.
Now most higher level animals are going to be osmo regulators where they can adjust
how much water they take in or take out based on the environment and so they adjust it
already they have essentially the ability to adjust to whatever environment they are
and keep it at the same level and that would be an osmo regulator and again they either
take up more water when they need it if they're in a hypo osmotic situation or lose water
if they're in a hypo osmotic solution and so that's the idea in these situations.
Now marine and freshwater organisms have opposite challenges and so if you have a marine fish
so this is how osmo regulation works in a marine fish so this is a saltwater water these fish
always have to constantly drink water because what's happening is they're constantly trying
losing water because in marine water there's more solute outside than inside the body so
water wants to go out it wants to dehydrate the animal so the fish has to constantly
take in and water and if it doesn't take in enough water it's going to eventually die
and so the way that it regulates it is again not only does it gain water from salt ions
in the food but it also gains water by drinking sea water then what happens is they secrete
ions out to keep the water in and then again the biggest issue they have is a lot of osmotic
water loss through gills and other parts of the body because water wants to escape it
wants to go into the direction of where the salt is.
Big thing with saltwater fish is that they don't secrete very much water from their
urethra because their kidneys again are balanced enough to make sure that most of the water
stays inside so they don't secrete a lot of water and so they're not going to pee a lot
if you want to look at it that way in the general term a saltwater fish is not going
to pee a lot because they want to conserve as much water as possible they're already
losing it through their skin.
Now fresh water fish is the opposite most of the salt is inside the animal so all the water
is going to rush in and if they don't control it they're going to blow up and so in these
cases they basically don't really drink water because water is coming in and doing those
things so they're up taking salts and ions through food in through their gills and then
again water is trying to come in.
Now they're going to excrete a lot of water because again water is keeping in so they're
going to be excreting a large amount of water and again very dilute because they want to
keep the salt in because again that's going to keep them from excretion of salt and large
amounts of water to dilute the urine and dilute the urine because again they want to get rid
of the water, water is trying to come in because it's trying to dilute them and again
that could cause them to explode so they got to really pump that out so fresh water fish
is going to pee a lot if you look at it that way and so again that's the idea.
Saltwater fish they want to keep as much water in because they're losing a ton of water fresh
water fish are trying to push as much water out because they're gaining water all the
time and so that's the difference and that's what would happen if you took a saltwater
fish and I'll put it into fresh water they would actually in this case blow up because
they're drinking a bunch of water and they would just swallow up like a balloon and same
thing would happen to fresh water fish that are used to getting rid of the water now they
would really dehydrate and that would not be a good thing either so you never want to
mix these two up and so again it's due to their fresh water or again those kidneys.
Now land animals have mechanisms to rent dehydration some of this is the body covering
so on lizards and that stuff and mammals and that stuff you have skin which is characterized
minimize water loss a lot of animals have scales to prevent water loss and they drink
water in these meat moist foods and they also produce water metabolically so when they go
through and do you know ATP production that stuff they make a lot of molecular water as
a process of making ATP so splitting the oxygen making water is also important as well okay
so again getting as much water as they possibly can.
Now the other issue that animals have is nitrogenous waste and this is due to the breakdown
of proteins and amino acids and nucleic acids and nitrogenous bases so eating itself we
eat a lot of protein we make a lot of the nitrogenous waste and so in order to get rid
of that we have to do something with that and so again not only proteins but also nucleic
acids have lots of nitrogen and so the organism cells have to get rid of the nitrogenous waste
so there's one of one of three ways that animals get rid of it they convert it to again some
type of ammonia or ammonia group and then get rid of it to excrete so the first curve
is the again aquatic animals that will secrete ammonia so just NH3 make it very easy most
birds and reptiles and insects and other land animals will secrete uric acid which is a
very complex molecule again and then for the mammals amphibians and sharks and some bony
fishes we basically secrete urea in the form of urine and that stuff and again we'll look
at how the kidney works here in a little while but these are really the main nitrogenous products
we make to get rid of the nitrogen and so again because nitrogen can be very toxic and
that stuff so we have to get it out of our bodies and so ammonia can be toxic to the
body so the quicker we can get rid of it the better off we are and so that's the key whenever
we think about excretionness not only keeping the water but getting rid of the toxins that
are in in the body now like I said ammonia excretions most comic and aquatic environments
most terrestrial animals secrete urea and again it's a conversion product ammonia which
is much less toxic so again we can hold it in a bladder and it doesn't cause as many
problems and then insects, land, snails and reptiles including birds secrete uric acid
which is a semi-solid paste so the bird poop you actually get is not only food but it is
also their nitrogenous waste and so that's the paste that you see associated with that
and so again all these things are less toxic than ammonia and it generates very little water
loss but it is energetically more expensive because then doing that to produce because
again you have to go and convert it all and so that's the problem you get this ammonia
byproduct and then you got to convert it into either uric acid or urea which is more expensive
than just secreting out ammonia in these situations okay now in most animals osmo regulation
and met about waste disposal rely on transport epithelia and so again these are cells that
help move things across membranes and so that's going to be the key step so when we talk about
blood and capillaries again you're going to have these solutes going across the movement
along with water and that's where you're going to see this and again these cells are specialized
for moving solutes across in controlled amounts across specific things and so they have terrier
proteins and all these other things really built in so that they can secrete and transport
nutrients one way or the other and so this is what we see especially in kidneys so you
can see here sodium going in and out associated with potassium and then sodium and glucose coming
out through the tubular fluid and that and so we'll look at all this stuff we'll look at the kidneys
here in a few minutes we'll look at it okay now the excretion excretory system in animals again
many animals series or species produce a fluid waste by refining filtrate of dry fluids and so again
the idea is to filter so you filter the body fluids and so what happens is the blood comes in
you filter the blood runs along and so during this time what you have is a number of different
things you have reabsorption and secretion from the blood and so again reclaiming valuable
solutes that's the reabsorption part and then secretion is getting more non-essential solutes
and waste from the body fluids into the filtrate and then finally excretion which is getting the
nitrogenous waste from the body and so we'll talk about this the other key aspect of all this is
minimize the amount of water you lose during this and so we try and reabsorb as much water as possible
in the filtrate and you're going to see we really ramp up the concentration of a lot of these solutes
during the process of filtration and secretion or reabsorption and so you'll see this where
certain things are reabsorbed because they're really necessary other things are secreted back
in and again you're going to see the concentration of the solute go up where again because we lose a
lot of the water as we filtrate because it's very important we bring that back into the blood
in these situations now if we look at invertebrates they have a very simple system called pro proton
nephridia which essentially is these two fuels connected to inner openings and so the best example
of the photo nephridia is in these wonderful plenarium what they have are these tubes all the way around
and again these are fresh water so water's constantly coming in and they've got it excreted out so
what they do is they essentially have these silly and other things that will take the interstitial
fluid convert it over transport out and then pipe it through these tubes which they'll excrete out
through the external environment and so they make a very dilute uh urine uh because again they got
to get as much water out because they're in a fresh water environment water's coming in to try
and dilute them out so they gotta excrete as much water out as possible so these animals would not
survive without an excretory system because they just get big and bloated and eventually blow up
because they they can't deal with all the fresh water that they that they live in and so that's the
key that they gotta get they have to have good excretion systems to get the water out and now
in insects because they're on land again they want to minimize the amount of water so again the big
thing is the nitrogenous products and so again the male piggy and tubules which are associated
right around the mid gut and that will remove any of the digestive waste and nitrogen that's in the
fluid filled sealum and again these things again will bring the ammonia and other things and then
they'll convert it into uric acid and then it's all secreted out the same opening as the dry waste
with the rectum and so again when they poop they're essentially exploring out their uric acid as well
so the dry pace and this is the same very similar now birds don't have men they'll piggy and tubules
but they do make uric acid in that and also in reptiles and so they have one excretion system
along with the one digestive exit which is the anus and so in birds and in reptiles they just have
what is called the cloaca and they expel out all their dry urine or uric acid as well as their
food waste as well in these situations okay now invertebrates again invertebrate
animals again some slight differences like i said birds and reptiles are a little bit different
but invertebrates we have in other coordinates we have glucidines which function both in osmo
regulation and excretion and again it consists of tubules arranged and organized in array with
the network of capillaries and then the excretory system includes ducts and other structures that
carry urine out of the body and so in the human we have the kidneys they're can again
emptied out through the ureter that goes to your ear bladder and finally excreted out
through the urethra and then out of the body and then again upper upper vertebrates and mammals
they have two openings again except for the ductile platypus which has the cloaca but in
everything else all the other animals have both an anus and then a urethra in those situations and
so you'll see that as we get into the further animals except like i said the birds the birds the
reptiles and the frogs but again mammals pretty much i'll have that where they have the two openings
in this case so again when you look at the kidney structure the the kidney has the two parts you
have the renal cortex and the renal medulla and this is the series of tubules in here and we'll
talk a little bit more about what's going on you also have these capillaries around it and then
you have the renal pelvis which is basically the collection the collecting ducts of the again
the renal medulla which collects the fluid and then works its way to the ureter and then empties
out into the bladder where the urine is held now inside the renal cortex you can see that you have
these tubules and then the medulla has the loop of henlay which we'll talk about here in a minute
and then they have the tubules descending down into the the the the junction down here and again
we'll look at that as we we talk about that and so these are the nephrons and these nephrons are
necessary for filtering and and getting rid of the the nitrogenous waste and we'll look at that as
well as reabsorption of water so we'll take a look at that as well now this kind of gives you an idea
of what the nephron looks like so again you have the collecting duct which then works its way out
to the ureter and that stuff but what you have here is essentially this capsule and this is called
the balman's capsule and essentially this is where the capillary will filter all the different things
out out of that the fluid and the solutes out of the blood in this case then it gets into the
proximal tubule and then it works into the loop of henlay which we'll talk about here in a minute
and then it works its way around and then finally ends up in the collecting duct. The reason why you
have both capillaries and the sloop of henlay is very important for again the two parts the
reabsorption of solutes and then also the movement of other solutes and waste into the
into the loop and so we'll take a look at this as well as getting water out so that will be the
other other part so again getting as much water out of the kidney or out of or keeping the water
I should say out of the urinary system and getting most of the water out and making sure it goes
to the right spot okay so again the mammalian kidneys ability to conserve water is the key to
terrestrial adaptation again the basic unit of the mammalian kidney is the nephron and in the
human kidney filtrate forms when the fluid passes from the bloodstream into the lumen of the balman's
capsule so that's where the initial fluid goes into the nephron and then what you're going to see is
then going through roughly 1600 liters of blood flows through a pair of kidneys every day so that's
a lot of blood so your blood gets recirculated all the time and when your kidneys don't work then
you have to get dialysis which does the work of your kidneys and so again filtering your blood
yielding about 180 liters of initial filtrate so we don't pee 180 liters every day so you're
going to see a lot of this gets reabsorbed into the body and so you find out 99 percent of the water
and nearly all the sugars amino acids vitamins and other organic nutrients are reabsorbed in the
blood what gets released are the nitrogenous waste some salts and then a little bit of water and
that's what you see but because of this I mean this filter system is so important for life on land
because we retain 99 percent of our water and so again if we didn't have this we'd be really in
trouble we'd have to be back in the water because we lose too much water being on land due to evaporation
and other things that take place and we'd be constantly drinking water to maintain
the liquid that we need the water inside of ourselves that we need now again it all starts
with the proximal tubule and the bone-ins capsule so the capillary comes in and you can see a lot
of the filtrate along with all the dissolved solutes in this case are released into this tubule and
so you can see these numbers represent the amount or the concentration of solutes in this case and
you're going to see the numbers fluctuate as we go along in these different things so in the
proximal tubule you start to see nutrients come in and out based on what is needed now certain
nutrients are required along with water is being pulled out and you start to see that again certain
ammonia and other things are added in so again this is where that filtration starts to take place
protons and ammonia are added in while certain nutrients and other things that are important
are filtered out okay and so that's the proximal tubule and again these things some toxic materials
are actually actively secreted into the filtrate to get rid of the toxins as well now we get into
what is called the descending limb of the loop of Henley so this is the loop of Henley right here
and again this is important for again maintaining water balance and so this is going to be the big
thing so when you see the descending loop uh our limb of the loop of Henley you're going to see a
lot of water come out this is where a lot of reabsorption of water as well as some solutes are
taking place and again it's because the concentration is going up water is being pulled through into
the kidney in this case and what you're seeing is because the water is being pulled out the
solute concentration is going up and so again you see this number okay and so reabsorption of water
occurs through aquapon protein channels the movement is driven by the high osmolarity of the
interstitial fluid which is hyperosomatic to the filtrate so again more solute out here than in here
because of the nutrients in that so that's pulling the water out passively through osmosis and again
the filtrate becomes increasingly concentrated as it works its way down because more water is
getting pulled out okay so that's the descending limb now it makes the return and goes up called
the ascending limb and so again this is called the ascending limb uh uh loop of Henley and again
in those these lack water channels so water doesn't escape now but what you're seeing is urea and
salts being pulled out in this case but salt salt but not the water is able to move from the
tubule under the interstitial fluid so you can see here salt is being pulled out because of the
high concentration of salt so that's being allowed to go through and then also what you're seeing is
urea being pulled in so the solute concentration actually goes down because of the salt concentration
but what you're seeing is is that other things are going in and water can't leave and so now it
becomes more dilute as you're working on because you have more water in this and less salt in these
situations so first pulls out the water then concentration concentrates the urine and then
more salt gets pulled out of this indication but the other things that's that stay are the waste
products and so you're getting rid of the waste but maintaining both the salt and water in these
situations to help with this process now we get up to the distal tube which is again next to the
proximal tube and now you see more salt being pulled out more water being pulled out and then
you get potassium hydro and proton ions in this case and again concentrations regulates those
concentrations and then the ions contributes to the pH regulation in this case so that it stays
neutral pH in this situation then you get the collecting duct where again more water and salt
being pulled out concentrating the urine as well as urea and other things and so again depending on
a number of different things the regulation of herbibility determines the concentration
of urine and again we'll talk a little bit more about that when we talk about hormones and again
it depends on how much water you drink depends on the concentration of urine so the more water you
have in you more likely you're going to get rid of it because you don't want to have too much water
in your body and again the less water you have the more concentrated urine is going to be and
you know this you drink a lot of water during the day your urine is very clear when you don't drink
a lot of water during the day and that stuff and you've been working out and doing all those things
it comes out very yellow and very dark and almost almost then orangey color because it's so concentrated
with nutrients and salts and other things like that that again it comes out a different color
based on the amount of water you have in your body at the time so you know you're really dehydrated
this again just shows you the whole part of this and how this works and again it's a constant
pulling in reabsorption of water reabsorption of salt and nutrients and then pulling that out
and concentrating it to get the waste out so the idea is maintaining the solute the solute of salt
and water in the kidney and getting that out of the filtrate but putting the waste products in
and so that's going to be the key making higher concentrations in that stuff the higher concentrations
are going to allow for again the for the movement of water one way or the other in these cases and
again biggest thing is the loss of the waste and so even some drugs and that stuff we know pass through
they can be pretty quickly in that stuff now the mammalian kidneys ability to conserve water is the
key for terrestrial adaptation and again the looping hemli loop of hemli and the surrounding
capillaries act as a countercurrent system meaning that they're pulling water out and then you're
multiplying the solute concentration so the system evolves active transport thus an expenditure of
and energy and again this system's called a countercurrent multiplier system because essentially
what you're doing is pulling water out through osmosis and active transport of the salt but what
you're doing is you're collecting and collecting the waste products and just allowing yourself to
conserve the water and salt but get rid of the waste products and those things and so this capillary
the vasarecta kind of goes along with the loop of hemli and you can see where things are being pulled
in and pulled out during this and that's why it's called a countercurrent because you're pulling things
out and adding things back in all the time as it passes around these systems. Now variations in
nephron structure and function equipped of kidneys of different vertebrates for osmo regulations one
of the big differences is the desert dwelling mammals how do they do this and so again they're
going to have the most hyper osmotic urine meaning they're going to have the most salt in those because
they want to conserve as much water as possible because where they're losing their waters through
evaporation the most where they're losing it whereas an animal like a cow which is not a
hyper osmotic environment is going to lose most of their water through urine even though they have it
the big difference is the nephron if you see the nephron in the desert animals they're going to
have much longer nephrons to pull out more water and more salt and get more waste into concentrated
then you're going to see in a nephron in a cow or something that doesn't have that's not in a desert
environment because again water loss is not as critical in these animals as it is in a desert
animal you need all the water you can get so they're going to have the most dilute or i'm sorry the most
osmotic hyper osmotic urine in these animals more water retention and then less water retention in
those that are in normal environments if that makes sense so animals that are not in desert
environments are going to let more water go because they don't need to worry about as much water loss
in that whereas desert animals water is the key and so you want to lose as little water as possible
and so you can see the difference in where water loss actually takes place in this desert rat
most of their water loss is going to be through evaporation not through not through urine or feces
whereas in a terrestrial cow most of it is actually through urine loss in this case in not so much
evaporation okay so other mammals can control the volume and osmolarity of urine again through
the kidneys and the length of kidneys kidneys of the south american vampire bat can produce either
very dilute or very concentrated urine depending on the water quality and again this allows for
bats to reduce their body weight rapidly or digest large amounts of protein while conserving water
and again the key is protein again when you break down proteins you produce that ammonia waste and
you got to get rid of it and so that's one of the big parts of not only osmo regulation but also
eliminating the ammonia waste and so that's the key in those situations so you want to remove
that ammonia waste okay now we do have homeostatic regulation this is one of those things and so
our bodies our homelands can control how much again how much urine we're going to produce and
one of those things looks at again the hormonal inputs and outputs of kidneys and again this
contributes to homeostasis for blood pressure and volume one of the things you can regulate as
calcium in the in the body and so again depending on what happens in these situations fall in
blood calcium levels cause the kidneys to uptake more calcium and again more calcium release from
bones and then as you eat more then that lowers and then this all goes down and so you can see that
just on the regulation of calcium now other ways that we can regulate our our volumes is by using
hormones and again the antidertic hormone or ADHD makes collecting the duck everything in the
temporary temporary more permeable to water so if we and again this is a good good show so much
show what happens and so this is the water content of our normal blood if we have too much salt or
we sweat a lot then our water content goes low we're dehydrated our brain will say okay we need
to drink water it will produce more ADHD which will cause for more absorption of water in our kidney
and our urine output below you probably don't pee very much during that day when you're sweating a
lot or eating a lot of salty food or whatever you don't pee as much now let's say you now start
drinking a lot of water and now you drink too much water now there's so much water in the blood that
it's high the brain will produce less ADHD from the pituitary gland and then what will happen is that
now you'll have a lower volume of water uh reabsorbed by the kidney and so now the urine output would be
high and so now you produce more urine that way or maybe you have to go to the bathroom more often
because you drink a lot of water and so again this is one of the ways that we can regulate our bodies
our brains uh figuring out how much water we need based on how much water is in our blood so again
less water more water is going to be absorbed more uh hydrated your the more likely you're gonna um
have more water in the blood so again shutting the system down and then releasing more urine so
more water loss in that case and that's kind of cool so your system can regulate that going
back and forth with the ADH. Now there's also this renin angiotensin aldosterone system or
retinone is the RAS system that regulates kidney function and so again a drop in blood
volume and pressure causes the RAS to increase water and sodium reabsorption to increase the
pressure. The other thing that gets produced is this peptide called angiotensin II and it's a product
of the RAS system and so what happens is again ADH gets produced in the aldo and that says the
kidney okay reabsort the water and sodium so you now get more blood volume and more cardiac output
that will increase the pressure and that will also increase and I learned this out the systemic
vascular retention which is basically a higher blood pressure in that and then again vascular
retention in your blood so again you'll have more uh pressure and osmotic pressure going on.
This is also triggered by this AI2 and then that can cause an increase in this pressure and blood
volume in that so you can see that you have multiple systems that are regulating the amount of water
that's going in there. Now some people have a problem where they produce too much A2 and then
they get what is called hypertension because they have too much blood volume and cardiac output or
too much arterial pressure so they have too much high blood pressure in this case and so one of the
drugs that they take actually blocks this AI2 production and so that will lessen lessen the
amount of water in this case in the body and so you're excreting more water in this case now
and you're lowering the blood pressure so you probably didn't realize this but your kidneys
actually regulate your blood pressure as well so if you have good working kidneys your blood
pressure should be in a normal range but if you eat too much salt and other things that's why salt
is bad for you because it affects the kidneys, diabetes are bad because it affects the capillaries
of the kidneys and that stuff, it destroys the kidneys over time and so then you lose and then
you get these other complications like hypertension, high blood pressure, all these other things that
cause some serious problems and so that's an issue. So like I said angiotensin raises the blood
pressure and decreases the blood flow in the capillaries in the kidneys and then like I said
if you have chronic high blood pressure some of these drugs that we take actually will block this
A2 or this angiotensin 2 and because of that it will cause the kidneys to lower the amount of water
tension and then lower the blood pressure because again more water, less water in the blood,
the blood pressure goes down and so again that gets a warranted dehydration state and so
those that are on hypertension a lot of times will then complain that they get thirsty a lot
because of that and same with diabetes because you're getting more sugar in the blood and that
stuff and that's a whole another situation okay so it just shows you a little bit about in humans
how we can regulate our kidneys and again how we can regulate the amount of water loss and water
gain and osmol regulation in our bodies. So we made it to the end of the video hopefully you learned
a little bit about the kidneys today I know I didn't get into too much but it showed you a little bit
of the differences between the vertebrate animals and how they secrete and that stuff and you can see
that the kidneys not only play a role in getting rid of waste but they also play a role in osmol
osmol regulation and that's what the first bullet point says is that the shared system mediates
osmol regulation and excretion in many animals so again the key is making sure that you maintain
water being on land one of our biggest problems is holding on to the water that we have and so
you don't want to lose that water through peeling it out and evaporation so again the kidneys make
sure that we retain most of the water that we don't urinate it all out and that we're constantly
happening during water so again water gain and loss in cells and then the romania removal of ammonia
and that's again the breakdown of proteins and nucleic acids in the body producing this nitrogen
is waste okay and then the mammalian kidneys ability to conserve water is the key to terrestrial adaptation
it's a counter-current multiplier you saw as it went through the loop of Henley it was pulling water out
increasing the solute concentration then pulling the salts out which is lower is the concentration
but you are also in gaining waste in those things in urea and then the system kind of goes along and
moving along these different concentration ingredients and so that's where the counter-current
concentrations mean and then again the desert animals have the longer loops you saw that they
have longer to maintain to get more water out so better water conservation so again in in
regular animals they tend to have shorter loops of Henley then desert animals begin because again
water loss and so most of water losses through evaporation not through urine excretion and then
regulation we saw with hormones especially adh the brain can control how much our kidneys are
reabsorbing water by how much water is in our body so again blood flow if we have low water
concentration in our blood our body is going to say okay time to reabsorb more water produce a more
solute or hyperosmotic urine in this case if it's the opposite regulation we have too much water in
the body the body's going to slow down adh and then the water is going to be excreted more in the
kidneys and you guys know this like i said if you just look at you know and i'll get into the bathroom
humor and that stuff but you know when you drink a lot of water your urine is very clear or very
dilute in that in that case whereas um or very diluted in the case of when you don't drink a lot
of water or even you haven't drank a lot of water during the day and you may have been working out
and that stuff and you already feel the taste of thirst and that because that's another thing
that gets triggered is your thirst sensation goes up when instead your body is saying drink
more water drink more water you didn't drink enough water that day your urine is very concentrated
it's going to be very yellow almost like an orgy color if it's really diluted in that stuff and
that's because your body's trying to conserve as much water as possible so it's a very concentrated
urine okay so hopefully you learned a little bit about the kidney today and that stuff this kind of
goes along like i said with the rest of chapter 32 looking at uh homeostasis and regulation and
temperature regulation and that stuff so it's kind of another contributor to that but hopefully
you got something out of it if you do have any questions about the kidney or how we osmo regulate
and that stuff for more explanation please ask in class that stuff otherwise thanks for watching
and I'll see you next time.